i love this guy i'm thrilled to be able
to call him a
friend not just a friend of the program
he's in the new film
shoplifters of the world he also plays
deathstroke
in the snyder cut of justice league who
also enjoyed him
in true blood and magic mike and uh
you could basically say he's as
multi-faceted as the 20-sided die he
plays with within his uh
in his uh his dungeons and dragons club
he's
joe mangano how are you joe how's
you know me very well yeah i do when was
the last time you so when's the last
time you played dungeons dragons was the
last time a little d d
for you i haven't been playing i've had
i've been swamped with work with
launching
these movies a week apart from each
other and then uh some other stuff that
i'm filming and then something else i'm
working on it's a writing deadline so
i've
been locked in a little over my head
lately so dungeon of dragons is kind of
like the snarter cut of games right
takes forever and uh and it's highly
enjoyable right
it lasts forever yes yes except ours are
like yeah it's like four hours a night
at least i mean with with my guys they
want to go till two in the morning
so come on uh it's like usually like
seven hours
how are you you good everything good in
your world i'm doing good
you're busy you know busy so just
keeping busy um and finding
finding new ways to keep busy so um so
not but i've been good we've been all
right over here we miss seeing you and
susie
exactly i feel the same way about you
guys too
and um you know and and congrats on the
film you know
uh i saw the review in the new york
times and um
a buddy of mine who does a lot of our
our work around here
he gives us all this great uh arts and
crafts and he makes uh our coasters and
he makes a whole bunch of stuff for our
cedarspillsum.com friend tom person he
sent something for you and uh
and sophia because he watched your movie
he loved it he loved what you said you
hit what uh hit gene simmons in the face
or something like that
so yeah he had a real sense of humor he
was great he allowed us to use his
likeness on a mug
that uh that gets shot by a gun
um and and uh you know posters and
things like that what's this movie about
for those who don't know
joe for people that don't know there's
an urban legend
uh uh in that in 1987
when the smiths broke up a young man was
so distraught
that he uh held up his local
hair metal station at gunpoint and
forced them to play nothing but smith's
records all night long to impress a girl
he was in love with
wow uh and and so
uh you know years later we we we made
that movie actually i think like the
movie airheads was inspired by this
by the story and um and so we're here to
tell the
you know story that was that was loosely
inspired by those events and it's also
about a bunch of kids on the eve of you
know when you leave high
school you're at that age what am i
going to do with my life we're all going
to leave our humdrum town
and it's about these kids and how much
of an impact the smiths had on them and
then this like
this one night in their lives this one
eventful night in their lives that
so happen to be the night that the
smiths broke up do you remember the last
cassette tape you bought joe mangano oh
my god the last cassette tape
um the last cassette tape i mean i
remember
i had all the old eighties metallica
albums
i had um appetite for destruction so it
probably would have been somewhere in
in that in that age okay did you have
did you have the tape deck in your car
did you have that too sure and then i
actually had that
the tape that goes in that connects to a
little cd disc
man that you put under your seat
actually one time
i had the adapter for an eight track
that you would put in there and then you
put the cassette in the
tj you're looking at me like that
actually existed yes where it would pop
up you'd put the cassette and it would
fit in your eight-track slot of your
dashboard
i had the one that had the record you
put the record in it and it had a string
that played very strange that's very
strange but oh my gosh
so uh what would the football version of
this be that uh
you you you hold up uh what uh or you
you stopped i guess the selling of uh
sandwich
at uh pramani brothers until juju smith
schuster signs long term
you only got a one one year out of it is
that what i was the football version of
shoplifting
at the uh letting go of stephen nelson's
contract
that uh i went down danton and held up
uh sammy's
corned beef that's the shoplifters of
the world version of the steelers
offseason oh mike hilton came back like
tyson
joe canelo is pulling him all out right
now so
i mean i gotta tell you joe i'm
genuinely concerned about your team's
2021
season even though big ben's decided to
come back that was um
i'm i'm i'm worried i'm nervous for you
that the browns and the
and the ravens are even the ravens it
took them
a few shots at getting a veteran
receiver until sammy watkins said yes
for
for one year 5 million but i'm concerned
for your team i'm not going to lie
what do you think well i i think it is a
very unusual year
so i think a couple of factors went into
that number one you've got a lot of the
deferred pay for ben roethlisberger
all of a sudden catching up you know
it's like driving your station wagon
around for 17 years just throwing
cups and wrappers into the back and then
slamming on the brakes all of a sudden
um you know so there was all of that
money to be handled and then on top of
that you have this coveted cap
so you know we're looking at 30 million
less in a year that we also
the third factor is we have 24 free
agents to sign
including you know half of the defense
of starters
so you know it's an unusual year and
it really honestly unfortunately comes
down to money
and what we can do with money on a year
where we had more money we're keeping
bud dupree
we might even just we might even get tj
watt you know are there jj what you know
it's such a it's such an odd year for us
and we're just doing the best that we
can to keep our team together
given the financial circumstances got to
get the running game i mean
i mean last year last year it was you
know after 11-0
the whole free football world knew you
weren't going to run it and then when
you're going to throw it it's going to
be somewhere in
10 yards beyond the line of scrimmage
and it
it just fell apart you know what i'm
saying despite um everybody's best
intentions and then when bud dupree goes
down i mean my goodness
well bud and don't forget devin bush
also so our linebacking core those are
those are two
all-pro caliber players that go down in
the middle of your
of your defense that that i think was a
championship caliber defense up to that
point and
like you're talking about the running
game you know you need a running game to
keep your defense off the field
you know if you're going in there
passing you know and you're three and
out
you know with a pass heavy offense you
haven't taken any time off the clock
your defense hasn't rested now they have
to come right back out that's going to
catch up to you at the end of the games
and
honestly that was a formula that worked
for steelers for the steelers for so
many years which is why i think there's
such heavy conversation
right now about that 24th pick going
towards a running back
and then of course who's going to be
available um obviously if if somebody's
not available to our liking at that spot
then we're going to go offensive tackle
but you know given the nature of the
draft over the past decade
you know it's not uncommon for a really
great running back to be available
you know at the end of the first round
all right let's talk uh let's touch the
third rail
um even though it really isn't that i
might be overdramatic but uh
who do you want to be the next
quarterback what do you want them to do
you want them to draft one you want them
to
uh wait it out make sure you see you
know knock on the the jet store for sam
darnold maybe during the draft
um what do you what do you as a steeler
fan and what do you think steelers fans
as a whole
want post big ben since this looks like
the the uh the swan song here well
you know you never want to say i want to
lose so many games that i'm
in position to get a hot quarterback you
know and and that actually was the deal
the year that we got ben you know we
picked high in the draft we usually
don't pick high in the draft we're
usually competitive so
you know if we're going to draft one
that means we're going to have a bad
season and that means that we're going
to be high enough to get one so
um you know without that being said i
don't know you know sometimes you get
lucky in later rounds
so i think the steelers are a team
that's going to draft their quarterback
um anybody that they bring in is just
going to be a band-aid
yeah it just seems to me darnold would
fit
i don't know i just really i'm just as a
jets fan you you want us to
get sam darnold i do because i think he
deserves it i think he deserves of uh
i mean the one thing that he's been
missing joe more than anything else is
consistency
namely a more consistent um organization
than than the team you root for
you know i mean like it's not going to
he's not going to lose his coach and
he's not i mean i know colbert does one
one-year deals but you know in the front
office
they are who they are you are who you
are you know what i'm saying and that's
the one thing he has not had was
consistency at all and i i i don't know
and he's tough he's tough as nails
um and and and clearly though the uh
you know new york and the jets is not
the spot for him i mean what you're
saying is you believe that he is an ap
caliber student we just need to get him
to a different high school
with better facilities i do think so yes
joe you know and i think
i'll i'll drive him to the high school
for you
if you're willing to cough up a first or
second form uh that might be too high
that might be too high i i mean would
you would you
would you take a third no because i saw
what you got for mink if it's what you
gave up for mink if it's patrick and
he's been such a homeless
sam darnold like we're talking minka
versus i mean mink is like a perennial
all pro
i'm trying to talk into it i don't know
what if i give you the cloak of
invisibility and you don't have any sort
of uh
issues with it let me go talk to kevin
colbert i'll get back thank you very
good
um when's the first joe manganiello here
on the rich eisen show a few more
minutes left with uh with my buddy when
was the first time you saw the snarter
cut
the first time i saw it was a few weeks
ago uh they sent me an advanced link and
and i watched it in four hours straight
with sophia of course i mean but i mean
how
how cool must that have been for you
right i mean you must have really
what what'd you think when you hit play
on that joe for because you know how
many fans have been clamoring for it you
know demanding it
saying it exists wanting it to exist
hoping it exists and now it exists
what was that like for somebody who was
actually in it as deathstroke
well i'm really happy for zach number
one um
because i think it's really vindicating
i think that he got to go back and
finish the movie the way
he wanted to and the result is is
you know people are the fans love it and
everyone agrees that it is you know it's
it
i'm glad that he got to take his time
and tell the story the way he wanted to
so i'm happy for him you know the thing
about it is i technically wasn't a part
of justice league that was their movie
i was just there to advertise my batman
movie
uh and and then you know to my surprise
a few weeks before
the movie came out theatrically uh the
joss whedon version
uh they called me and said you know we
re-shot your scene to advertise at
justice league too instead of batman
because you know it's not happening
um and so you know for me i was
yeah i'm really just i'm a passenger you
know on on this
on this ship and kind of involved by
default
but when zach called me up four years
later and said you know how'd you like
to put the suit back on
what do you think would you know do you
want to come and do this i i said sure
yeah of course and it was
that was zach inviting me into his
universe because otherwise like i said i
mean
the the actual scene that fans get to
see at the end of the snyder cut is
is the restored scene the way that we
shot it advertising the batman movie
i mean dude your career i mean the names
of your characters
right first of all your current film
shoplifters of the world you're a full
metal mickey
um you're a deathstroke in this film the
snyder cut
your big dick richie and magic mike yeah
if you notice i i laid in all three
words on that one yeah
obviously al seed er ervo from
true blood i mean my god flash thompson
dude
you there's there's you're just joe in
real life you know what i mean and and
you're this is pretty incredible i mean
which one
which one is the most you big dick
richie
that's a great answer now let me tell
you why no
it's the only answer it's cause your
dancing skills it's because you're
dancing that's the one it's like i mean
i'm like
look at you it's a male stripper movie
not really the way i planned my career
to go
but how am i going to say no to playing
big dick richie
soderbergh for stephen soder soderberg
but you know look there's a big dick
richie
what are you gonna do to say no what are
you crazy i would say what if you
what if what if there was uh something
called a soderberg cut for magic mike
but every cut for soderberg is a
soderberg cut
so you know what i mean well yeah i mean
i had uh stephen you know steven knows
what he wants
so when he shoots there's no there's no
real
you know there's no there's no fat on
the meat it's super lean
you know i saw magic mike you're right
you know or he'll get everything in one
taken
he's best friends with david fincher
who's notorious for doing 78 takes i
remember asking stephen
how are you guys friends how do you guys
not just beat the
heck out of each other you know how can
you you know stand each other if you're
like he's like now we just you know
we're friends we just have
very different ways of getting what we
want and and that's the truth
no doubt about it man uh joe thanks for
the call best to your lovely wife uh
i'll send you these goods i have no idea
what my buddy tom person sent for you
and your wife but he's a big fan of
yours and wanted me to
tell you that it's on the way i will
make sure you get it i hope you enjoy it
and let's uh let's let's chat again soon
let's get together
and hopefully we can see each other soon
i would love how's bubbles the dog
bubbles is on my lap right now taking
her morning nap
okay um the entire conversation has had
the whole time man she doesn't really
like it when i'm on the phone she wants
me to get off and pay attention to her
you know
shut up so she can sleep well she's
she's literally what six pounds
she's 4.8 what
so she got fat in the pandemic is what
you're saying
yeah she put on the pandemic a little
choice eight ounces
uh yeah i know it's funny i started like
working out in the backyard i set up
some stuff so i just mix it up and okay
i'll just do i'll do squats with her on
one shoulder you know just pick her up
there and
do some lunges around the house to
switch holders with her
there she there's a photograph there's
bubbles looking through the door
okay so send my best to give her give
give her a little belly scratch
and uh and i hope i'm not making her
jealous just by talking to you so thanks
for the call
take care brother everybody check out
you bet same here to uh sophia best
shoplifters of the world available in
theaters on demand
and digital now good stuff joe
manganella
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here